this is a Super Glide mouse pad it's
pulsar's first premium glass pad and
while it looks incredible it's playing
catch-up the glass mouse pad Market has
been dominated by Sky pad for a long
time they've produced some of the
highest quality hard pads for years but
his pulsar's Super Glide pad both
cheaper and better than the sky pad
let's find it
[Applause]
alright so first off I just want to say
thank you to Pulsar for sending me their
new pads to test out this video is not
sponsored by them though so as always
I'll be completely honest with my review
they sent over both a red and white
extra large PAD as well as one black pad
in their large size the XLS are 490 by
420 millimeters and the large is 420 by
330 millimeters to start things off
unboxing went well which is what I've
just come to expect from Pulsar glass is
obviously pretty fragile so I was
slightly worried that the pads might get
damaged in shipping but thankfully they
were all extremely well packaged thick
pieces of foam help secure them in place
and once you take them out there's a
plastic sleeve to pull off my immediate
impression was that all three colors
looked great especially this red Supreme
looking version which I'm sure a lot of
people will go for the Super Glide pad
also uses lines of molded high density
silicone along the bottom which I've
never seen before on a mouse pad this
thing didn't move once I put it on my
desk even when I applied quite a bit of
pressure to it and that's great because
there's nothing I hate more than a mouse
pad that shifts around on my desk one of
the main reasons I've used Artisan pads
lately is because I like how sticky the
surface is on the bottom but these Super
Glide pads are just Next Level now
truthfully this was my first time using
a glass mouse pad I typically use slower
control pads because I'm a low sense arm
aimer so to conduct a proper review I
wanted to try something else and luckily
my boy Daniel from Addis was kind enough
to hook me up with a sky pad 3.0 so make
sure to go check him out I really
appreciate his help with this he even
sent me the Yuki aim collab which I did
not expect at all but it's honestly dope
skypad has pretty much been the goat
when it comes to Glass pads lately and
when I opened mine up it was clear that
it's a high quality product the surface
looks and feels very similar to the
Super Glide but one thing I did notice
is that since it only has four rubber
feet in each of the corners there is
some Flex when you apply pressure to the
center of the pad it's not something
that I think would affect your aim but I
did prefer pulsar's solution it doesn't
have any flex and just feels more secure
overall the XL version of the sky pad is
is wider and the Super Glide pad is
slightly taller overall I prefer the
size of the XL Super Glide because it's
the same size as my Artisan but that's
just my own personal preference next I
want to get into my practical review
I've never tried Super Glide skates
before because I've heard that they wear
down and I just figured that they'd be
too fast for me and that's kind of what
happened I tested all the pads with my
DeathAdder V3 Pro my Pulsar X2 and of
course my super light these are the
three mice that I use the most the Death
Adder and X2 both had stock skates on
them and I used core pads on my Super
Glide for the second and third week of
testing make sure you're using PTFE
skates on these pads by the way if you
use glass skates then you'll probably
scratch the surface and likely have no
control over your mouse anyways once I
hopped in the range on valorent I
noticed that both pads are extremely
fast as expected they're faster than
anything I've used before and it's not
even close I lowered my sense a bit to
try and compensate as I continued
testing my micro adjustments felt much
better than I anticipated but I often
struggled when I was trying to track
targets up close there were a lot of
moments where I just felt like I didn't
have enough control for a game like
valorant and I think that's all right
because unless you grew up playing on
glass like some CS Boomers then I don't
think you'll find many attack FPS
players using this surface skypad even
says that their surface is optimized for
games that require High Time to Kill so
if I played games like OverWatch Apex
and maybe even fortnite then perhaps
these pads would suit me more but as
many of you know all I really play is
valorent and old school RuneScape
something that I didn't really care
about but my friends in Discord
definitely mentioned is just how loud
and Scratchy these glass pads sound any
dust or hairs falls on them then you
might even hear a slight screeching
sound and again this honestly didn't
bother me but it definitely bothered my
teammates so if you're sensitive to
noise or maybe you play games without
headphones on then watch out as for
durability none of the pads have shown
any signs of slowing down on me so far
and if you do happen to get any dust or
debris on them then they're extremely
easy to clean another thing that I
really liked is the fact that I can
actually play on glass with long sleeves
without it affecting my aim but now to
answer the question you've all been
waiting for which one do I recommend
when it comes down to Pure Performance
both surfaces felt nearly identical to
me I didn't find myself aiming better on
one compared to the other but I can say
with certainty that the overall quality
of the Super Glide is higher the
silicone on the bottom is insane and the
pad just feels more sturdy on my desk
the XL Sky pad does retail for roughly
15 dollars more than the Super Glide so
unless you're a weeb and you really just
want an anime waifu to look at then I
recommend going with the super vibe that
being said since the sky pad is an older
product you're more likely to find it on
sale every once in a while but if you
already own a sky pad then I don't
really see any reason to go out and buy
a Super Glide pad and although glass
might not be for me I can guarantee that
these are easily some of the best glass
options out there
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock